es el eje central de la política
exterior de Brasil según lo han afirmado
varios expertos con los que hemos
hablado y es que ellos argumentan que la
amazonía regula las precipitaciones de
lluvia en todo el mundo y seguir
adelante con las tasas de deforestación
que se han venido dando los últimos años
en la mayoría Afecta no solamente el
Brasil y el hemisferio sur sino Estados
Unidos las precipitaciones de lluvia en
Estados Unidos también se ven afectadas
si continúa la deforestación Así que
Lula viene a compartir Pues esta Promesa
de campaña ese objetivo de campaña con
el que llevó la presidencia de Brasil
que es de tener completamente la
deforestación del Amazonas no solamente
para bien de Brasil sino para bien de
Estados Unidos también y para proteger
el mundo de una eventual crisis
alimentaria Cristóbal Quiénes acompañan
a Lula y que otras reuniones han ido en
Washington además de las que se conocen
en la agenda
Exacto pues la agenda de hoy empieza a
las 12 y media en la casa Blair al
frente de la casa blanca con reuniones
de Lula con congresistas entre ellos
Sanders pero pues esta mañana se
conocieron que Marina Silva la ministra
de ambiente precisamente tuvo reuniones
con líderes ambientales y con otros
miembros de ong y detentan acá en
Washington a las tres y media de la
tarde será la reunión oficial entre Joe
biden y signario a las cinco y media
Lula ofrecerá una breve conversación con
los medios de comunicación a la salida
de la oficina del salón de la casa